مشاهدينا ننتقل بكم الى الامم المتحده في
نيويورك حيث تصوت الجمعيه العمل الامم
المتحده الان في هذه اللحظات على مشروع
قرار يدين الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
انتقل الان الى مشروع التعديل في الوثيقه
اي على احد عشر على التسعه
طلب تصويت مسجل على مشروع التعديل a على
اي اساس 11 على التسعه سنبدا عمليه
التصويت الان ارجو من الوفود المؤيده
لمشروعي
التعديل
التسعه ان تعلن ذلك تلك المعارضه وتلك
الممتلئه الجمعيه العامه تصوت الان على
مشروع التعديل a على
نرجو من كل الوفود ان تتحقق مصحه برود
اصواتها على الشاشه
الجهاز
نتيجه التصوير
المؤيده 15
المعارضه احدى وتسعون
الممتنعه 52 مشروع التعديل على اي اساس
على التسعه لم يعتمد
بما ان مشروع
التعطيلين ايه على اي اساس 11 الثمانيه
علي احد عشر التسعه لم يعتمد سنه تتوجه
الان البث في مشروع القرار على اي اس 11
على 7
الجمعيه العامه ستعمل الان على البث في
مشروع القرار على اي اس احد عشر السبعه
بعنوان
واقتبس مبادئ وميثاق الامم المتحده التي
تقوم عليها التي يقوم عليها السلام الشامل
والعادل والدائم في اوكرانيا نهايه اقتباس
طلب تسجيل تصويت مسجل سنبدا عمليه التصويت
الان الوفود المؤيده لمشروع القرار ايه
على اي اساس 11 السبعه نرجو منها ان تعلن
تاييدها وتلك ممتنعه وتلك
المعارضه
الجمعيه العامه تصوت الان على مشروع
القرار على اي احد عشر على السابعه
بعنوان مبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده التي
يقوم عليها السلام الشامل والعادل ودائم
في اوكرانيا
ارجو من كل الوفود ان تتحقق من صحه ظهور
اصواتها على الشاشه
نرجو اغلاق الجهاز
نتيجه التصويت كالتالي
المؤيده
141 دوله المعارضه سبعه
الممتنعه اثنين وثلاثون مشروع القرار على
117 اعتمد
دي فوقي قبل اعطاء الكلمه
لتعليل لتصويت بعد التصويت اذكر الوقود
الموقره ان تعديل التصويت محصورون بعشر
دقائق وتدلي به الوفود من مقاعدها
الكلمه الان
لمندوبي او مندوبتي
سيدي الرئيس
عن استقلاليه الدول وسلامه اراضيها
وسيادتها وحق الشعوب تقرير المصير ونحن
نعرض
بالكامل استخدام القوه او تهديد بذلك
ونؤيد تسويه السلميه لنزاعاتي والخلافات
قبل عام مضى تقريبا وفي هذه الجمعيه
العامه حزرنا من ان تاريخ سوف
يطالب
الحكومه الامريكيه بتحمل مسؤوليه نتائج
نظاما عسكريا يمتد خرج حدودها ويهدد
السلامه والامن والاستقرار على المستوى
الدولي في اوكرانيا اليوم
وبدلا من تخفيف من حدث التوترات فقد
ازدادت حده المواجهات الميدانيه عبر
التزايد في نقل الاسلحه والخطابه العدائيه
وفرض الجزاءات احاديه الطرف مما يساهم في
تمديد
الصراع لقد امتنعت كيوبا عن التصويت على
مشروع القرار السبعه
وجدنا ان هذا القرار لن يساهم في تحقيق
الحوار ولن يفي غرض المفاوضات بمشاركه كل
اطراف المعنيه بهدف الوصول الى سلام
صادقا وعادل
وان هذا السلام هو مطلوب مطلوب وبالحاح
اليوم لا يمكن لنا ان نؤجج من نيران صراع
ان يتسبب يوما بعد يوم بسقوط القتلى
والجرحى والالحاق الضرر المادي ترفض بلادي
اي محاوله لتلاعب هذا النص كاساسا قانونيا
لتبرير اقامه محاكم في المستقبل تهدف الى
اجراء محاكمات على المستوى الوطني والدولي
ليس للجمعيه العامه ولايه لتفعل ذلك ان
كيوبا مستمره بمدافعتها المستمره
ومطالبتها بحل دبلوماسي يكون واقعيا
لتسويه الازمه في اوكرانيا عبر سبل سلميه
وفي اطار القانون الدولي الذي يضمن امن
وسياده الجميع
والسلام والامن على المستويين الاقليمي
والدولي وشكرا اشكروا مندوبه كيوبا الموقر